[Music]
America's Got Talent is back for a brand
new season that was amazing all brand
new
all brand-new excitement we have a brand
new host
miss Tyra Banks
[Applause]
I call my mama and I said mom I had the
opportunity to host America's Got Talent
should I do it she's like ha mr. Cowell
and tell him yes yes and guess
Tyrel be funny comfortable honest if it
works out I take all the credit and if
it doesn't it's other people's fault
that's what a teepee does we've had
magic acts danger acts ridiculous acts
in these two villains I have a gas it is
very different than helium cybers I am
your worst nightmare every year when I
feel like I've seen it all there's
someone that does it even better and
this year I am obsessed with the chicken
then this chicken can play the piano I
chicken just played America the
Beautiful this is his story
I just think America's Got Talent is the
best show the entire family can sit down
and watch it I love finding talent I
love being part of someone's dream
done anything like this before you have
just become a star knowing that you can
change people's lives it's a very very
special feeling I never think I'm gonna
be surprised or amazed and then you turn
[Applause]
[Music]
you